- All right, I think we're ready to start.
Anyone else wants to join us
for the talk with Scott
Cook, Founder of Intuit.
I'll just start for everyone
here at Khan Academy
who doesn't know,
both Scott and Signe Cook
are some of the earliest
believers in Khan Academy, and supporters.
And to a large degree, Khan
Academy wouldn't be where it is
right now without a lot of their help.
And so I just feel like I owe you guys.
But with that out of the way.
- We're just fans.
We cheer from the stands.
The players who win the
game are in the room.
- Very nice, well, thank you.
(audience laughs)
The point of having you here,
and whenever we have
people of your stature
come to the office,
we think it's just a
valuable learning experience
to have a conversation with you,
and then to see what's
going on in your mind.
The place I like to start,
before we open it up to
the rest of the team,
is you see a lot of folks
who've done big things, like start Intuit.
When I was a kid, I always wondered,
how does that happen?
How do you go from being,
having a normal job, and
one day you start a company,
and that company becomes
a really big company?
Tell us a little bit about that story.
How did Intuit get started?
- I think for you it
was your niece, was it?
- My cousin.
- Cousin.
- Cousin, yes.
- For me it was my wife.
- [Sal] Very good.
- She was struggling with
her math problem, no.
(Sal and audience laughing)
She had to do, she does
our joint checkbook,
and she was complaining about doing it.
She was very good at it.
She's diligent and mathematical,
but it was a hassle
because she had to pay the bills,
and you had to rewrite it in
the check register, reconcile.
And she complained, and I thought, huh?
This was in 1982, when PCs
were just starting to explode.
I said, wait a minute, this
sounds like the kind of problem
everybody might have,
'cause everyone's gotta have a checkbook.
Everyone has to pay bills.
And PCs are now going into homes,
and this is very solvable on a computer.
This is the kind of task that
computers are very good at.
I thought, oh, maybe I'll write
this software just for fun.
But I hadn't programmed in a decade,
so I figured maybe I should get somebody
who actually knew what they were doing.
And so I found a student
at Stanford, Tom Proulx,
and he and I co-founded the company.
And with the goal of building
a simple piece of software
that would allow people
to eliminate the hassles
of managing their daily, monthly finances.
- And how do you go from that?
Because what you see a
lot of in Silicon Valley,
and other places is, you saw a need,
you were able to build
a prototype to do it.
But then there's a big jump between that
and actually getting traction,
actually people using it.
How did you make that leap?
- Yeah, for us that leap
between launching it,
and actually getting a
lot users was not a leap,
it was a chasm.
(Sal laughs)
It was a crevasse.
(Sal and audience laughing)
Software at the time was
sold in stores in boxes,
and you took money,
and we tried to get VCs
to invest two million dollars
to give us the marketing money
to convince stores to carry it,
and then convince people to buy it.
And no VC said yes.
They all said no,
including VC firms run by classmates.
Shows you how unpopular this idea was.
That was a big problem.
Yeah, we borrowed some money.
We got a little bit of seed
money from some relatives.
We stumbled along.
We spent that.
We ran out of money.
We had to give back the rented furniture
and rented computers.
We stopped paying salaries.
It was pretty ugly.
- And why didn't you just,
I mean, it was stressful.
- Yeah, our marriage almost broke up.
- And, I mean, given that,
why didn't you just cut your losses and?
- I think cutting losses
would've been the
rational thing, actually.
It did look so hopeless.
But I felt I was kind of boxed in
because we'd borrowed this
money from some people.
I had taken my father's
retirement money, most of it.
We had the two relatives
who'd invested equity
as kind of angel money.
But I felt I had to pay that back.
You looked at the amount of
money I'd have to pay back
through honest work if
I had quit the business,
so I felt trapped that I can't give up
because then I gotta
pay all this stuff back,
so we just kept working.
We just kept working at it.
- And at some point, how are you living?
How are you paying your bills?
- Fortunately, Signe had a very good job.
In fact, in either this building,
or in one of the adjacent ones.
- [Sal] Next door.
- Yeah, she worked in a software company,
software publishing corp that had
a bunch of these buildings.
She in VP marketing, so
she had a very good job.
It was her income that paid the bills.
- How long did this,
I guess this crevasse,
how long was this period?
And then what was the moment where
actually all of the
sudden you saw the light
at the end of the tunnel?
- Well, and it's actually
even worse than one crevasse,
there were two.
Something we tried started to work,
and then it crapped out.
And so that's even worse
when you get let down.
Let's see, we launched the
product with great hope
in October of '84.
And it was the time when
I finally felt the thing
was doing well enough
that I could buy something
that wasn't a necessity,
something optional,
that I could splurge on,
which turned out to be a CD player.
When I finally could afford
a CD player was in late '87.
- Wow.
That still was, this was a story,
it was still, it wasn't like
a hockey stick at this point.
- No.
- It was still a slow and steady.
- And so, the question you
asked, let me answer it
directly the question you asked.
What actually did turn
the business around?
It turns out it was word of mouth.
Because the way we built the product
was different than others had.
Nobody up till that point.
Software was an industrial
product, sold to corporations.
The big software success was VisiCalc,
which was sold to finance
people in corporations.
And the UI sucked.
You couldn't figure it
out without training
or reading a book.
But that's the way software was.
We were the first people
to do consumer testing,
usability, we didn't call it
that, but usability testing.
We brought housewives in
from the Junior League
because at the time,
there were all these women
who didn't work during the day.
And they didn't use computers.
We put them in front of computers.
We gave them our stuff, and said, okay,
use it to pay a bill.
And they'd fumble and goof,
and we'd look at 'em and say,
oh, shit, we didn't.
Oh, oh, yeah, now I see.
We'd go back and redesign
it, and we'd try it again.
And refine it, and have people
who didn't know the product,
no manual, try it by hand.
We had done more cycles
of usability refinement.
Nobody had ever done that before.
So our product was actually usable,
and fast compared to the,
and we're selling to people in homes.
No executive's telling them
to use it, they gotta want it.
And so people starting using it
from earlier and feeble marketing,
and then they'd start
telling their friends,
and they'd start telling their friends.
And there started to be demand, pull,
and it was the word of mouth
that ultimately took off.
- And then it just is, the rest is--
- Yeah, we started tripling.
Every year we'd triple in size.
Triple, triple, triple.
- You went into the most
obvious adjacent spaces,
taxes, and?
- Well, it was, I've learned
something about surprise.
In fact, the first question
we talked about today was,
what's been surprising?
- [Sal] I told him about
our burglary situation
when he asked that.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Sal] The upside and
downside to surprises. (laughs)
- There's learning in surprises.
We had, we were in our first,
we launched Quicken, and
even before it took off,
and was just failing and bumbling along,
we did a little survey
of the few users we had.
And you ask them all these questions.
And one question made no sense.
At the end of the questions,
where we were asking
about how do they use it,
what do they like, not like, et cetera.
At the end there was a demographic set.
You ask age, location, income.
And we asked a question,
where are you using the product?
Home, office, or both?
And half the people claimed
to using it in an office.
Well, this was a home product,
so we thought, well, maybe they
don't have a home computer.
I mean, this was 1984, 1985.
Maybe they're taking their stuff
to work and doing it there,
so we ignored it.
Every subsequent survey, the same answer.
Half the people were
using it in an office.
Well, we ignored it.
It didn't make any sense.
Finally, it started bugging me.
Why are people answering
this question wrong?
(audience laughs)
I said, well, let's go ask
those people what they're doing,
instead of ignoring it.
This was years later.
We went and actually
called some of them up,
and asked them to interview them.
Went to visit them, see
what they were doing.
And by God, a lot of them
weren't doing their home stuff,
they were running a business on it.
We'd built this as a checkbook manager,
not business accounting.
And the mindset everyone had
is that business accounting.
Talk to any, who's took accounting?
Who's an accountant here, any accountants?
Okay, very good.
Now, what's the system
by which you keep books
for a business in accounting?
- Double entry.
- Double entry accounting with debits
and credits and journals and ledgers.
Any expert will tell you,
that is the only way,
and we assumed that.
Here we found these
businesses using a tool
that had none of that,
no debits, no credits,
no double entry of anything.
And, what?
But they're using it, they are
running their business on it.
It's where all the expenses
and the income flows through.
It's their accounting system.
And then we tried to find out, why?
Why are they doing this unexpected thing?
Now it's obvious in hindsight,
but of those of you who
took accounting in school.
Raise your hand if you
Okay, how many of you
liked accounting in school?
- I actually did like it.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, I got it.
You and I, we're both weird.
But the rest of you are normal.
Most people hate accounting.
And the people who keep the
books in a small business,
tend to be owner, the owner's spouse,
an unlucky clerk or
assistant, office manager.
Nine times out of 10, they
do not know accounting,
and they do not wanna learn.
To them, general ledger,
which is a feature of
all accounting systems,
is a World War II hero.
(audience laughs)
That's why they were using our product
because we were in English,
and they didn't have to learn anything.
Where all the others, was
a massive learning curve.
We finally said, whoa, what would happen
if we actually built a
product for businesses?
But made it on the same promise,
with no debits, no credits,
no journals, no ledgers.
Put it in plain English.
You see an invoice, you fill it in.
You see a check, you fill it in.
So we worked for that,
on that, launched that.
It all came because of a surprise.
Today, that business, which is QuickBooks,
is in total about 10 times
larger than the Quicken business.
That surprise, which we ignored for years,
has created a business.
And if you add all of
our small business stuff.
We've added payroll and
payments and all that,
it's about 15 times the size
of the Quicken business.
I didn't recognize it at the time,
but there was a pattern about
when there are surprises,
big upside or downside,
savor the surprise.
What's really going?
What explains it?
That's not what we expected.
Stop and savor it.
It's too easy to just keep going.
Anyway, I've learned multiple times.
That's the story on some of
our subsequent businesses.
- Now I know, when you ask me questions,
that there's like an
underpinning philosophy.
- They're not random.
- That's interesting.
- They may seem random. (laughs)
- No, that's very good, you're
having more thought than me.
Now, before I open it up,
where do you see Intuit going?
It's a much larger company now.
How do you as the leader, or the manager,
how do you try to navigate that?
Where do you see as the big
opportunities and the pitfalls?
- Oh, the pitfalls are clear.
It is amazing how success
and scale make you dumb
in an organization.
It is just stunning the degree to which
the creative, inspiring,
innovation, invention,
suddenly starts disappearing
as you grow, you add layers.
Decision makers, managers,
try to get rigorous,
and do all the stuff
that you have to do to be
both efficient and to be reliable.
People don't want their,
I mean, we did launch
a version of QuickBooks
where your data disappeared.
(Sal laughs)
Randomly after, all your data disappeared.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, this is a problem.
You don't really wanna do this.
Don't try this at home, kids.
You gotta get rigorous,
but something happens.
Without continued innovation,
without continued,
how do we make the current thing better?
How do we find the next problem to solve?
You eventually get stale and die.
How do you be both rigorous and inventive?
And most importantly,
how do you free your
most inventive people?
Who are often quite new to the company,
could be quite young,
likely are renegades.
How do you free them to
invent without the Borg,
the organization borging them?
We're redoing how we work
along the lines of lean experimentation.
The thing I've learned is
if you allow normal hierarchal decisions,
you have the problem,
all the problems happen.
Well meaning, middle
managers, it just slows down.
But what if you tell the middle managers,
your job isn't to make that decision?
We'll let the experiments
make the decision.
Middle, your goal is to
put in systems that allow
your teams and your brand new employees
to be able to take their best
idea to solve your mission,
and run it as an
experiment, fast and cheap.
The internet now allows us
to run these fast, cheap experiments,
so there's this whole wave of change
called the Lean Startup
that Eric Ries has founded.
I've not seen any idea
enter the common parlance
of business as fast as the Lean Startup.
His concept of Pivot went from
novel to tried in two years.
I've never seen it.
It's been absorbed, at
least as language, so fast.
But he wrote the book about startups.
I believe there's two groups
who need the Lean Startup
even more than startups,
this concept of lean experimentation.
And those are large
companies and nonprofits,
will benefit even more than startups.
We're trying to operate as a
network of startups inside,
where people can try their ideas.
And we've got coaches, teams, systems.
We put people through a two-day experience
where people just sign up, and
by the end of the first day,
they have their idea up and
running in some sort of test,
to test their leap of faith assumption.
All to uncork that inventive power that is
what has created all great
enterprises in Silicon Valley.
- [Sal] Yeah.
- So that's kind of,
and if we do that right,
then I won't have to pick a direction.
Our people will invent the
directions far better than I can.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, on that note,
I'd love to take questions.
Anyone have questions?
I have a bunch more if anyone.
- We started the company
with a bunch of surveys.
I had described one that
helped us get the surprise
that led to QuickBooks.
But I have become a skeptic on surveys.
I actually don't guide
teams to run surveys.
I tell them, avoid the survey.
We've found there's
not a high correlation,
particularly if you're looking
at inventing new ideas,
and new businesses, new products.
There's not much of a correlation between
what people say they will do
and what they actually do.
What they say they will do,
they'll do about half the time.
So that means, it's a coin flip.
We've had, oh, we did a product
in India, which we have,
which we surveyed users.
We were trying to figure
out how to monetize it,
so we surveyed.
We expected 20% would pay for it,
because we'd been giving it away for free.
We surveyed users and 40% said they'd pay.
And then we actually did the test,
and took existing users and
added a charge, and 2% paid.
There's another example.
A team working in payroll division
had a new way for a business
to start up payroll.
They mocked it up in screens,
showed it to 20 payroll customers.
These are employers.
Someone here runs a system
to write your paychecks.
It'd be that person.
Zero of the 20 said they'd use it.
Zero.
Amazingly, they didn't stop there.
Thank God, they didn't stop there.
But because of our system
of experimentation,
they then got coached.
We actually had Eric Ries in coaching.
He figured out a way you could
run an experiment in 24 hours
to actually see what people would do,
not what they say they would do.
They ran the experiment, and
58% of real customers did it.
If they'd listened to the survey,
we never would've done this thing.
Because they could take it to a test,
a test of just a slice of it,
they then learned that
the customers would.
We fleshed out and built the rest of it,
and we got the fastest
customer growth in 10 years
in that business.
What I've learned is trust
behaviors, don't trust surveys.
Measure and monitor their behaviors,
and then right after behavior,
you can ask somebody,
why'd you do that, or why not?
Then you might get
something close to truth.
And do it more as an in-depth interview
of the people who just did something,
or in a test just didn't do something.
And then you might learn something useful
from the interview.
When we go out and talk to customers,
and interview and observe,
one thing we'll do is
go and watch customers.
I find it's much more reliable
to watch people in what they do.
And you've got an opportunity.
You've got people at home,
studying or whatever,
where you could go watch
and see actual behaviors.
Don't say anything, just watch,
and you'll see things they
would never comment about.
I'm on the board of the
Procter & Gamble company.
They make soap, Tide, and
Pampers and other things.
In trying to figure out
how to improve Tide,
they'd run surveys.
One of the many, obviously,
you've got many things you ask about,
one of which was the box, the packaging.
They asked, is it easy?
And the answers in the survey were,
yeah, it's easy to open.
Well, years later, they did
some in-home observation.
They followed some homemakers
around watching what they did.
And they then did observe
a few people opening
a brand new box of Tide,
and they found it was easy
if you kept a knife or a
screwdriver next to your,
and 'cause women have nails,
and they couldn't open those things,
so they were hacking at it.
But it had never come up in a
survey, but they could see it.
The thing I'd recommend is to
understand customers deeply,
go out and watch them.
We call it follow-me-home testing
because we used to follow
customers home from the store.
Not exactly, we'd ask
for permission. (laughs)
(Sal and audience laughing)
So we could watch them start up.
Well, let me answer that in two parts.
One, the story of how
we got into payments,
and then the crystal ball gazing.
There was actually one guy, an engineer,
an African immigrant,
who looking at our QuickBooks users said,
huh, they really could use payments.
In fact, what they need's different
than what everyone else is selling.
He got a product manager to work with him.
And the two of them cooked up this scheme,
and inserted it into the product.
And, by God, it took off.
'Cause they'd found a
problem for businesses
who accept payments when
there's no card present.
Because QuickBooks is typically
used in the back office
around invoices, and some customers wanted
to pay with a credit card over the phone,
but there was no card present.
The whole payments industry
had been rooted around
that card being the key.
They invented a different economics
and a different approach, and
embedded it in QuickBooks.
And so now we have a payments business
that's 400 million in revenue, sizable.
All because they found a
problem nobody else had solved,
and figured out how we could solve it.
Now, on gazing about the future.
Right now, you're seeing a hotbed
of innovation around payments.
Things are becoming dramatically easier
to send money person to person.
Send money for businesses,
for businesses to set
up and accept payments.
It's long been, payments,
a kind of monopolized
or cartelized business with a
few major payment utilities,
such as Visa and Mastercard,
or one central bank run system
called the Automated Clearing House.
And now this rampant
innovations happening around it.
It's so much innovation, and most of it,
I can't tell you how it's gonna turn out.
But it's gonna get a lot easier
and cheaper for everyone.
The place we're focused on
is still in the back office
because everyone else
tends to be focused heavily
on the point of sale,
but the place that's still being ignored
is that business that sends
bills or invoices out.
And, for example, in rent payments here.
How many of you pay rent?
Raise your hand, okay.
How many of you pay that electronically?
Most of the hands went, right, yeah.
Especially small landlords are not set up
to accept electronic payments.
And it's a royal pain,
for you, and for them.
They gotta hang around the mailbox,
waiting for the money to come in.
'Cause if it doesn't, they gotta bug you.
So a small team, how many people?
Yumi, how many people was
that team when they started?
- [Yumi] About two or three.
- Two or three?
Two or three folks said,
we can fix that problem.
And so they invented a
system called Spark Rent,
which allows the merchant to,
not the merchant, the landlord to sign up,
and then the tenants can pay
electronically really quickly.
The landlord can be anywhere, on vacation,
and they know everything.
It sends reminders out.
It's cheap.
It's had some hiccups,
but it's now the most popular way
that small landlords can
get paid electronically,
and tenants can pay electronically.
That's just the beginning
of the kind of innovation.
From that, what we wanna
do is develop a way
so that our system will know
that you pay your rent on time,
so when you try to get that
next apartment in San Francisco,
and there's five people
trying to get that apartment,
you've got a track
record that you can say,
you can trust me.
Here's my Spark Rent track record.
We think we can then take the data,
and make it useful to both sides.
When we're at our best,
yes, we can pull that off.
But that's a real, I'll admit,
we're far from perfect on that.
In our payments group, again,
we've had a group that came in
at a much lower price point.
Within our tax group,
a group was working on.
Right now, you go to TurboTax,
and you've gotta pay
your taxes on a computer.
But this group said,
why don't we use the phone?
And why don't we use the
phone to snap pictures
of those tax documents,
so you don't have to type it in?
Well, management thought
this idea wouldn't work,
and outside experts said it wouldn't work,
but they kept at it.
And they've built something
called SnapTax that works.
It's an app on your phone.
And you snap pictures of your W-2s,
and if your taxes are simple,
and a lot of you guys are,
it asks like nine more
questions, and you're done.
Nothing we have done in,
and it's at a lower price
point, and it's easier.
Nothing we've done in
our company's history
has gotten as high of
ratings from customers.
It's five stars in the app stores.
And we get reviews like you can't believe.
One person wrote in that
she was in the recovery room
after surgery doing her taxes,
and so happy about it.
(audience laughs)
Another guy wrote in the
review, in the app store,
that it was February 14th,
he just finished his taxes
in bed with his girlfriend,
and she's so stoked,
she might even wear the
gift he just gave her.
(audience and Sal laughing)
Again, it was a small team
who had the freedom to
experiment and invent something,
which is just, that the
mothership wasn't working on.
At our best, we do that.
There's other times when
I wish we were better.
This is the eternal
priority setting question.
(audience laughs)
No matter what size you're in.
Before we launched, we had
more features we wanted
to put in than we could fit in.
After we launched,
and now as a 4 1/2 billion dollar company,
there's much more stuff we wanna get to,
and that people wanna get to than we can.
I have two thoughts on that,
and they are kind of opposing thoughts.
One is, make it fast and
cheap to run experiments,
so you can try more things.
If it's big and expensive
to try something,
then you've gotta be choosy.
If you can make it fast and cheap to test
the leap of faith assumption
on which a decision depends,
then you can try a lot more things.
Eric Ries' Lean Startup,
we were already running experimentation.
And then I discovered Eric
Ries on an online video,
and I said, my God, that's our idea,
but he explains it a lot better,
and he took it a lot farther.
I'd circulate the Lean Startup,
and look at some of his videos.
It's really, it makes sense.
That increases your
capacity to try new things,
and to try new radical things.
'Cause if it's fast and
cheap, it can be radical.
The other, the principle is
that the actual important things
is a small subset of all the
things you're working on,
what's truly important.
Here's an example.
I learned this technique from another CEO,
to run a thing called a town hall meeting.
We'll get a group of
important customers together,
let's say accountants,
because we sell a lot of
things to accountants.
We'll get a group of 12 of
them together in a room,
and I'll stand up at the whiteboard,
and I'll ask them two main questions.
What do you love about
dealing with Intuit?
And each person write
down, private, silent work,
write down a list of what you love about
working with Intuit.
Second question, what do you
hate about working with Intuit?
What's wrong?
Where do we piss you off?
What are we just missing the boat?
Okay, silently, each
person write your own list.
Okay, then once they have lists,
I stand up in front, and say,
okay, let's read off list number one.
And everyone read their list one,
and I'm up at the whiteboard.
And I fill out the whiteboard
with all the great stuff.
I said, thank you, that's
great, that's awesome.
Now, let's go to question two.
Everyone tell me the lousy stuff.
And I write all those ideas down.
People will have real passion
about the stuff that's wrong,
that needs to be fixed,
and needs to be changed.
You'll get 30 items up there,
real passion from folks.
Then I'll say, okay,
let's forget list one.
Thank you for that.
Let's focus on list two.
I'm gonna give each of
you five colored stickers.
Go up to this whiteboard and
put those colored stickers
by the things that you
find most important.
You can put all five on one.
You can put one sticker on each of five.
You can split 'em up.
What amazingly happens,
out of the 30 or 35 items
that'll be on the board,
most get no votes at all,
not even from the person
who was advocating it.
The votes uniformly are
incredibly lopsided.
Now, they're not
collaborating to each other.
They're not comparing notes.
They're doing this as individual work.
The votes, there's one always,
every time I've done this,
one big one.
And then there'll be a second
that gets half as many votes.
And then maybe a third
that gets half as many,
and then it's noise.
Then what we do in the
meeting is say, okay,
let's dive into number one.
Okay, what's the problem?
What's the issue?
When does it happen?
How does it happen?
Tell us more.
What's the root cause?
Blah, blah, blah, how do
we go about fixing it?
And dive into number one.
Basically, you should work
with most of your effort
on number one, small effort on number two,
and forget the rest.
Organizations can't do that.
Organizations will work on 12.
Oh, Susie wants to work on this,
and boy that's a good idea from them.
That customer was so passionate.
So you'll get 12, and you'll
underwhelm the important ones.
And you'll spend much too
much time on the stuff
that just isn't.
This is the best example I've ever seen
how customers actually
are much more focused
on what's important than companies are.
And there's one big one.
I tell folks, what's the 1 1/2 things
you should be working on?
(audience laughs)
And then run cheap experiments,
so you keep the idea creation.
'Cause you'll get surprised
out of the cheap experiments.
That's your safety
valve, to get surprised.
That might be helpful.
(audience member speaking faintly)
Let's do a little show of hands.
How many people wanna understand
all the words in the tax law?
Raise your hand.
(Sal laughs)
How many people just wanna
get their taxes filed
and get their money?
(audience laughs)
Yeah, we're not in the education business.
That's your business.
(audience laughs)
We have found, at least
when it comes to finance,
most people are exactly like you.
They just wanna get it
over, and get the work done.
If they occasionally wanna learn more,
we've got a lot of what we
call point-of-need help,
where you can just click.
There's a little blue
underlined thing saying,
what is this?
Or, tell me more.
And people can click and learn more.
When they do that,
it's typically not
because they wanna learn,
it's because they wanna
make the decision right.
Even when they're quote, learning more,
it's only to make the
decision, and then move on.
What you're doing is
noble and really important
and crucial to the world,
but it's not why people tend
to buy or use our stuff.
Yeah, so, why did we acquire Mint,
given our passion for internal innovation?
It came way, we acquired
Mint before we had wrapped up
a lot of the experimentation work.
We're not as good as we want now,
but we were much less good then.
Also, I'm very eclectic.
We want innovation and innovative
teams from both sources.
We both acquire and we teach
and coach our internal,
and enable our internal entrepreneurs.
We do both.
We certainly don't,
I think it was Bill Joy
of Sun who once said,
almost all the smart people in the world
don't work for your company.
(audience laughs)
We wanna be where almost
all the smart people are,
which is, we're only one
slice of the smart people.
In this case, with Mint,
we had an internal effort
to do Quicken online.
Mint and some other competitors
were pursuing similar things,
and Mint just outrun the whole field.
They produced a better solution
that had a different business
model and was just better
than what we were doing.
We said, why fight a losing battle?
Let's go get the top team
and the top approach.
Since we've acquired them,
their business has tripled
or quadrupled in size.
Their ideas have infused
much of the rest of Intuit.
That was one thing we were hoping to have,
their ideas change the
direction of other businesses.
We've had them run the Quicken business,
so we could take their learning,
and we gave them the
Quicken business to run.
We really tried to maximize
the wisdom transfer.
Now we're building a Mint
product for small businesses.
Figuring they have such a
good thing for consumers.
Plus, we're adding much
more to the Mint data
and what Mint can do for you.
But we're also saying,
can we take that same magic
and solve problems for
small businesses as well?
That's some of the story on Mint.
Your premise is exactly right.
When you do your finances with any system,
it accumulates the data.
We've got a very large
repository of data on people's
taxes, investments, spending, business,
at a transactional level.
The first thing to recognize is
in my view, that's not our
data, it's our customers' data.
They allow us to be the
stewards of their data
only if we earn that.
We can only do things
that the customer wants
and gives us permission to do.
If we break that trust,
people will run from us,
and they deserve to.
The next thing is Mint was,
another piece of the
Mint DNA we wanted was
they were making better use of the data
than anything we've done.
We've largely done nothing with big data.
We've used the data to solve
your immediate problem,
but we have not then, the way Mint has,
said, oh, based on your data,
we can see that you'd be much
better off if you did X or Y.
That was another piece
that we wanted to do
to cross pollinate from
the Mint acquisition.
We now have a data team with a new leader.
We took one of our leaders
who's very talented,
and added this challenge to her.
The data team was focused on
how they could help Intuit with data.
We said, that's nice, but
what we really wanna do is,
how do we help the customers with data?
How can we change their lives?
We've reoriented the data team
on the mission that you described,
so that hopefully in a a year or two
we'll have more ways
that we can help people.
Here's just one that's already in action.
It turns out most small businesses
apply for a loan at some point.
70% of our QuickBooks
customers have applied
for a business loan.
And most small businesses get turned down
in a rather slow, long, ugly process
where they wind up giving
a lot of data information
and paper to some bank that
ultimately turns them down.
Plus, there's a lot of
lenders who'd like to lend
to customers they don't yet know.
We think we can make that happen.
Because of the rich data in QuickBooks.
We can help figure out who
is a good lender for you,
and then make it easy for you
to apply with a push button,
instead of filling out all this paper.
And then have the lender
be able to rapidly approve,
and get higher confidence
that they're lending to good people
'cause we've got deeper data
on your business than anybody.
But we can only use it
with your permission,
but this is an area where
businesses really want someone
to take advantage of their data,
to give them a better
loan at a better rate.
We've got a lending operation.
We don't do the lending.
We work with lenders,
and we're trying to pioneer
this lending marketplace
using QuickBooks data as the
unique asset to make it happen.
That's an example,
and we're getting some,
a number of lenders are playing with it.
Our ultimate goal is to
build a better credit score
based on richer data,
so that more deserving
businesses can get better loans.
- I'll just finish up.
Obviously, you are known
as one of the top managers
in not only your industry,
but in Silicon Valley or more generally.
And you've known Khan Academy
since really the beginning.
What thoughts do you have
about what we're doing?
Where do you see the opportunities?
Where do you see the pitfalls?
What's your general thoughts
and advice for us as a team?
- I bet some of you are better aware
of the things to be afraid of.
I'm not sure I'm close enough
to give you a thoughtful
assessment of that.
But I think one thing that I
can't say is an issue here,
but has been an issue in
other fast-growth operations.
You grew from about five to
six million monthly actives
to about 10 million over the last year.
And you're doubling.
You're expecting a future like that.
Your superstars,
celebrities, in the press.
There is the curse of success,
where things are on a roll,
where everyone wants to talk to you,
which somehow is a drug that causes people
in other organizations to
take their eye off the ball,
to stop focusing on two things.
One, what really solves
the customer problem?
Yeah, yeah, customers are using it,
things are great, we don't
have to worry about that.
Companies can persist in doing things
that ultimately are second rate,
just because the second
rate stuff was better
than what was before. And
they don't find out the great.
I mean, think of Overstock.com,
who then just got surpassed
and crushed by Google, or by eBay.
Or think of Yahoo!, which, gosh,
they were the darlings,
huge, the internet company.
And then Google just went
(making jet engine sound) by 'em.
Because they stopped focusing on,
okay, what's the major problem to solve?
And how can we innovate and
solve it much, hugely better?
Yahoo! always was a place people came to
to go somewhere else, and
their search was not good.
Stick to the knitting of,
what's the fundamental
problem we're trying to solve?
What do people really want us to solve?
And are we the best in the world at that?
From what I see, you're working on that,
with the dashboard and that.
The other curse of success
can be the curse that Friendster had.
Friendster was the social
network before Facebook,
and even before, what's
the music one out of LA?
- [Sal] Myspace.
- Myspace.
And they had taken off
as a social network,
Kleiner Perkins, major VC had invested.
They asked me to go down and take a look.
I went and talked to the
entrepreneur, and that was good.
But he talked about,
they ended up talking about
some technical problems.
I dove in to learn more.
He wasn't getting along
with his technical founder
or technical guy at all,
and the system was crashing.
It just couldn't keep up with demand.
It was collapsing,
and ultimately that killed Friendster.
One of the things that Mark will say about
why Facebook succeeded is he had seen
the collapse of Friendster,
because of technical problems.
They just couldn't scale with the volumes.
And he and Dustin Moskovitz
were just determined
that was not gonna stand in their way,
so they limited growth early on.
And then they just piled the resources
to make sure they were up and reliable.
Those are some of the things I've seen.
Other cases of companies running afoul.
I'm seeing seen good stuff here.
I don't know, don't know, don't suspect
that's happening here,
but those would be some watch outs from
the history of some
companies who, like you,
have been shooting upward.
- Great, no, thank you, that's--
- Let me just cover one more thing,
which is the other half of your question.
- [Sal] Yes, yes.
- Which was about, how
do I see the future?
Maybe I'm not very good
at seeing the future,
but I can see today.
And there's a, some of
you may have seen this,
there's an article that
was in Harvard Magazine
about a physics teacher there,
a guy named Eric Mazur.
Anyone's?
- Yeah, regularly.
- The article was entitled something like,
The Twilight of the Lecture.
Eric Mazur was a well respected teacher
on the physics staff there.
He'd been teaching physics
for a decade, I believe.
The tests that he gave showed
the students learned the subject
matter, and he's all happy.
Then he heard about the
University of Arizona
that had invented a capstone test
that tested kind of like the Common Core,
do people really get this stuff?
Could they apply it?
The results out of
University of Arizona was
after taking the semester of physics
that the physics students
there just failed this,
can you actually apply
it in real situations?
He looked at it and said,
well, that's interesting,
but those are University
of Arizona students.
There are Harvard students.
Almost all of his students, first of all,
all got a score of one or
two in their AP Physics.
He just as a lark, took the test,
and gave it to his Harvard students
after they'd finished
his semester of physics.
And by God, they failed it.
He said it was monkey level.
If you had monkeys guessing randomly,
you would do as well as his students did.
(audience laughs)
Now, Eric is an unusual professor
at a research institution
because he actually cared.
He didn't say, well, screw that,
and back to the research.
He actually said, wait a minute,
what does this say about me?
What am I doing wrong as a teacher?
I'm failing these students.
He dove in and tried to
figure out what was happening.
He has evolved from that.
One of my guys passed me the article,
and then we reached out to him.
And we actually spent some
time with him learning.
And he basically found out that
students don't learn from lectures,
even from highly rated professors.
They just don't seem
to learn from lectures.
And these are Harvard students.
And they don't learn to,
I mean, they learn to pass the basic test,
but they don't learn
to apply in a deep way.
He started trying alternative ideas.
He tried a very different way.
He's basically flipped the classroom.
And the students work on problems.
And then he can figure
out through a system,
which students got it and which didn't.
And then he'd have the
students who got that section
explain it to the students who didn't.
He said they're much better at it
because the student has
just tried it, didn't do it,
and now they're hearing from
someone who just learned it.
Who just is walking in their shoes.
And he says, now his
students ace this test.
I think there's a revolution in learning,
from something that was done to you.
Education was done to people.
Lectures are done to people.
To turning education on its
head, learning on its head,
so people, now it's up to me.
It now becomes something you do.
And you learn at your speed,
and you learn by doing yourself,
not by being reliant on someone else
to pour learning into your head.
You learn by using, you learn by doing.
And that's the way real
humans really learn fast.
You guys are in the vanguard
of leading that globally.
With the internet, with
the raw inventiveness of
the dashboard, the
on-demand, the lectures,
to understand how the students progress.
Creating a platform so
that math and then physics
and other subjects can be
taught by, learned by doing.
This will change learning,
and lifelong learning.
This is the invention of
printing by Gutenberg,
applied to a field that
desperately needs it.
And more than that, this is the,
the sum total of IQ points
in the world is fixed.
It's what genes have delivered to us.
But how you turn those IQ points
into productive human potential,
into skills to be able to solve problems,
to be able to see problems,
that is entirely a function
of people's learning,
and can be dialed up or down dramatically
by the learning method.
Compare when you've been in some class
which was boring, badly taught,
or the great research professor
didn't really know English,
and you just, your
learning rate is so slow.
Your love of learning
just goes into the toilet.
And then compare that to
a class where the teacher
was fascinating, where
you could move and learn,
and try things and they worked,
and you got this feeling
of accomplishment.
It's night and day.
Igniting the fire of learning
in billions of people
is a force of power far greater
than the printing press.
I believe you guys are the
world leader in doing that.
- Well, that gives us a
little bit of pressure.
(Scott and audience laughing)
But it's exciting at the same time,
and so I'll just on
behalf of the whole team,
I just really thank you.
That was really a special conversation.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)